i have beaten all souls games without
dying a single time do the math that's
right zero deaths
i have done this for years now zero
deaths
zero deaths stereotypes zero deaths zero
deaths i have never died in a video game
ever in my life
people all over the world are amazed by
my great gaming skills matt impressive
how pewds got a zero death run first
time playing the most impressive thing
is that they are the zero deaths wow i
can't believe zero deaths but some
people think i'm a lie and they say my
zero death runs are fake and that i
actually die all the time
this sort of behavior is completely
unacceptable
okay fine maybe i die once maybe twice
maybe 500.
what
no no no no no
what happened
cyril
that does not count because
my uh uh the girl vows
is fake lol he is fake this is no zero
death urged video zero that's
lies what shameless clickbait but i have
decided
my days of living like a fraud is over
my name is peter pat and i'm going to
beat eldon ring with zero devs
for real this time
okay
okay i may need a plan but first off we
need to lay some
say that rules one is obviously zero
deck if game says i die i die it's that
simple at least you think it'd be that
simple at the very start of the game
before you've done anything you're
greeted by the crafted sky and boss it's
one of those bosses that is just there
to humiliate you welcome to the game
you're dead congratulations now you can
keep going
okay so what if you just try hard enough
and kill the boss that you're not
supposed to kill in the beginning
will that be zero deaths
no because if you move on further you
literally just fall off a cliff and die
[Music]
fine kill the damn boss again don't go
in the cliff that collapses
turns out there's nowhere to go and the
only way to progress is to die
if i have to die here i might as well
just jump off right away anyway right
but this is clearly a zero death rule
break the best way to deal with this is
the best way to deal with anything in
life which is just get naked and hope
for the best
so even though the health bar
technically goes to zero the game
doesn't go out of his way to say that
you die therefore zero death runs still
possible no you die text zero death
applies that's rule one i actually want
to double check this because even though
you can never see exactly how much
health you have if you open up the
status menu and keep it open while it
hits you you actually see your health
going down to one not zero so
technically what that means is zero
different plugs
rule number two is no summons i think
they're a cool addition to the game but
the point of this is for me to beat the
game not my sexy twin okay rule number
three no fundamentally game breaking
glitches the wrong warp is a great
example if you rest at the belfry tower
of grace and do a little bit of game
breaking the game will place you in the
end game and you have successfully
skipped at least five non-optional
bosses so rule break last rule don't use
any weapons that are completely broken
or overpowered
i will use some cheesy strats but to
completely rely on just seems kind of
lame okay so i have the rules i have the
challenge now i just gotta figure out
how to execute it and for the record i'm
not good at these games and what i was
about to find out was that i was even
worse than i thought i was so i made a
plan step one make my weapon as powerful
as possible as quick as possible that
way on the first bosses i can go from
doing this
to this
before we continue i should warn you i
am going to bombard you with information
about this game things that you may
already know or you have not even played
this game at all but i'm going to tell
you anyway
the weapon i'll be using is the moonwell
katana i know i know it's not the best
katana in the game but it does enough
damage and it could do damage on range
which is super useful against some
annoying enemies but my favorite is that
it can stagger bosses very easily
oh and you can also get it very early
which is necessary so yeah for those
pipes you don't know you need somber
stones to upgrade your weapon otherwise
it's useless these are scattered all
across the map some being easier to find
than others one to five is actually
pretty easy to find some people use the
belfry tower cheat that i told about
earlier to get eight and nine i
obviously can't do this but i find you
can get them without cheating they're
literally right next to each other so
we're good this leaves just six and
seven in academy of reality there's a
secret passageway done under and if you
let mommy eat you you get teleported to
magma manor it should be called that
okay i don't care what anyone says you
can easily pick up number six and with a
little bit of parkour you can pick up
number seven bada bing bada boom you got
the best weapon in the
stop you actually have to die to do that
so i
i can't do that so i looked into other
methods and this falling star beast
actually dropped summerstone number six
and it's accessible in the early game so
i started practicing it
i'm not doing it i'm not doing it i'm
not doing it i'm not doing it i'm not
doing it i'm not doing it i'm not doing
it
so instead of worrying about my weapon
for now i started worrying about the
last four bosses which is going to be
the biggest challenge no matter what
malaketh godfrey radagon eldenbees if i
really wanted to do a zero death
playthrough i knew i needed to master
these four bosses the first of the four
bosses is beast clergyman or malikith as
he transformed into and on my first
playthrough i actually got him on the
first try first try
i guess i wasn't technically first
trying to think about it more
i rolled off
[Laughter]
that's [ __ ] gay
the thing is on this playthrough i was
heavily relying on my summon to tank all
the damage i had spent about 80 hours in
the game and i was much much higher
level and without all that i couldn't
even make it a phase two
and once i finally made it to phase two
it was like a punch in the face all his
attacks comes out of nowhere he flies
all over the place everything kills me
at an instant even if i know an attack
is coming i don't know how to dodge it
this [ __ ] thing that he does took me
so long to figure out how to dodge and
every time i fail i had to redo phase
one just to practice phase two once i
finally beat him once i was done i was
ready to move on practicing another boss
coming up next was godfrey the first
album in the word and i gotta come clean
about something here guys before the
boss you might notice there's a bunch of
blood pulls of people dying this is
because people try and jump this pillar
what happens is if you do it
successfully
then stand in the right spot and quit
out the game once the game loads up
again you'll have run into the boss room
without activating the boss and you can
literally just run past him however this
never worked for me no matter how many
times i tried it i think it has
something to do with my computer but
honestly i'm really glad it didn't this
jump it's just a stupid risk because
it's easy to mess up and i'd be skipping
one of the coolest bosses in the game
unlike malekith godfrey still hits hard
but his moves are pretty easy to predict
and this time i used a different
approach of just timing myself and not
trying to kill him just to see how long
i could stay alive i quickly went from
less than a minute to two minutes to
then even four and beyond and i finally
rebuilt some confidence that i had lost
from melee kid
i was then ready to move on to the last
two bosses ratagon and the elden beast
and guess what i got my ass handed to me
again
ratagan is really tough his moves are
either super fast or super slow and it
seems to be impossible to determine what
he's gonna do and if you mess up just
once you lose your tempo and then it's
easy to mess up again and it's not until
you finally beat ratagon that the elden
beast will show up i actually thought i
was doing okay on this until you pull
out the most [ __ ] move in the entire
game which is the chasing star things
you have to keep running away from them
to dodge them but he'll keep attacking
you like normal i can't see what the
hell is going on and every time he did
it i would just die i felt the learning
curve harder than ever here i had spent
about a week and a half and by now i
knew exactly what i needed to do to beat
this game with xeroden but it turned out
to be so much harder and so much more
work than i had initially anticipated
there's so many bosses that i hadn't
even tried at this point there was still
the fire giant god godskin duo reicherd
and morgan just to name a few
i kept thinking i should just give up
but the thing about these games is that
the more you play them the better you
get and the better you get the more fun
they are to play i just kept coming back
i try to not worry too much about the
goal of zero death at this point and
practice every boss just a tiny bit and
even at times i didn't think i could
improve i was still coming back stronger
every time these games get a lot of
flack for being too difficult but it's
also very clear that the game wants you
to learn
there's a way to respond to everything
there is in the game it's just about
finding out what that is and once you do
you feel like you're the boss instead
it's a little cringe but i felt like i
was finally getting there so it was time
for me to do my first live attempt
i've been playing elder ring i'm here
beat the game
with zero deaths
for real
oh gosh what do i do
[ __ ]
well it was a good try
i failed after 30 minutes because i
agreed an enemy by mistake attempt to it
actually did pretty well i had managed
to stay alive for about three hours at
this point and made it to the fire giant
i quit at the boss two times and failed
two times to do so and it was getting
very anxious i have never missed so much
in my entire life
let me leave
[Applause]
it's not good
the failed quit that i got as well
that's not good but i have the thing
it's fine
the built up pressure after three hours
is something that i had not anticipated
and i just totally failed i hate this
boss
on a side note i've seen some of the
dumbest takes ever about ellen rings ux
and ui but i think we can all agree on
that no one wants this text winner to
appear when you're jumping up on your
horse it looks like you're about to die
here are you sure you want to jump up on
your horse yes or no if you don't answer
you're dead if you do answer you're dead
yes i want to enter the goddamn horse
i can blame the game all i want but the
truth is i played terribly on attempt 3
i was back on the fire giant i had
practiced him a lot now but there was
one attack that he did that i wasn't
really sure how to dodge and it's when
he blows fire out of his mouth
and of course he does it the last god
damn second
you know i'm pissed off when the swede
comes out spoilers i kept dying
jesus
i might die
die
we're okay
we're okay
[Music]
okay that's the worst part
are you serious
i did it
oh god
no
what ah number two
oh what
you [ __ ] babe
baby [ __ ]
i'd spend all my time and effort
worrying about the hardest bosses
what am i doing so not practicing the
easy ones meant i kept making dumb
mistakes
[ __ ] you did the explosion this meant
having to redo runs that had spent
between two to three hours on and not to
mention all the random death that seemed
to keep happening
i got stuck somehow i just couldn't seem
to get it and every time i failed i
wasn't just disappointing myself but it
also felt like i disappointed everyone
watching i wanted to do one attempt
where i do it offline so i can just
focus on the game and at least then i
can show you guys everything i have to
redo every time i die i'll warn you
it'll be a lot but i want to be thorough
with it because that's what i would want
if i watched it so if you're ready here
we go
i use samurai class just because it has
good bass stats with the weapon i want
to use pick the greatest name of all
time then golden cedar starting item
just for the extra heal sorry about the
awkwardness of me sitting in the dark i
just thought people would question if
this was my footage otherwise i know i'm
supposed to let him hit me but i can't
help but fight back a little bit grab
this bonfire because we're coming back
to it in like two hours
i still call them bonfire whatever grace
grab this bonfire then we get a horse
after she queefs on us
why yes i am 12. hit this guy very
important it's like the shortest bonfire
distance ever but we are coming back
here in like an hour we cross the bridge
and then we find our first somber
smithing stone i am aware you can just
buy these but all of them are in the
ramp that i have i feel like i might as
well just pick them up it doesn't matter
then we run over to the first dungeon in
the game it's like the first dungeon and
they put a trap to put you in the end
game for players that just stumble upon
this chest it's so mean
and you can't even teleport out if you
get here anyway it's good for us because
we don't have to run as far i'm supposed
to stealth out of here but i kind of
messed it up and almost died
but we're fine we can get back on our
horse torrent and start running this
swamp is great because we find our spell
and staff that we need to kill our first
boss in order to get our actual weapon
rock sling and then the meteor right
staff
grab this bonfire nearby because we need
to head north but later on we'll head
south and on the way what's that number
four baby that's right it's almost like
we don't have to buy them we keep going
north to head to one of the caves i hate
this tunnel you saw me die here earlier
but anyway here's number two yeah i just
pick it up
it's literally on the way why not
okay so here's the scary bit you could
grab these rooms if you want but the
most important thing is the golden foot
that's down here
they literally come at you all at once
don't panic keep running keep running
keep running honestly it's not even that
bad of a part but losing 10 minutes this
kind of sucks and the fact that i've
died here before just makes you way more
nervous when you're doing it don't judge
me too hard on this all right i need to
kill alexander to get his tallest man
his talisman is really good is it make
your weapon skill even better if you
don't want to kill him you can do his
quest line and he gives you a better
version of the talisman but we don't
have time for that so just killing him
is the only way i'm sorry conveniently
the back of this cage goes exactly where
we want to go gotta kill that wolf very
important it's the third church of
marika we got our sacred tier and our
first physics drink you might have seen
this trick already where there's a
secret portal hidden right behind it now
we've basically gone even deeper into
kayla the area from earlier here we pick
up a golden seed which is great and uh
a starlight shirt we need that for a
boss later am i explaining too much
whatever
if we run down the hill we see our first
boss the knights cavalry and this trick
is actually really cool this boss is
clearly too high level for us but you
can trick him to jump towards you which
makes him fall off the bridge and die
which is always hilarious and super
satisfying but it's also very easy to
get stuck or just mess up the amount of
weird [ __ ] he's doing what the [ __ ] so i
learned this trick from one of you guys
in the chat and it's even funnier so
basically you make him follow you all
the way up the way you came and all
these poison clans will hit him so i
immediately thought this trick had
something to do with the poison and as
soon as you entered the top of the hill
and he followed you the entire way there
he'll eventually teleport back to where
he spawns
and then you'll just see the text saying
that he died it's so confusing no one
had a good answer to why they thought
this happened first we thought it was
the poison that maybe killed his [ __ ]
and the horse dies so when he teleports
back he falls off the horse and dies but
someone made a really good point which
is the fact that these games are
optimized to not load in things that
you're not looking at and when we're on
top of the hill we're not looking down
on the bridge anymore so once he
teleports back to the bridge he's
teleporting back into nothing and he
just falls and dies
i i love that theory and i think it's
true actually i just wish i could see it
i know this is a very cheesy strat but
it's too good not to use we also get
bloodhound step which is super essential
for later and 42 big ones hell yeah
there's actually three things we need
from this bonfire but they're all in
different directions so it's a bit
awkward on what we do first spend a few
points leveling up then we're gonna kill
the old paralyzed dragon this is
everyone's favorite part
it's so funny because people enter the
stream here and they don't know what's
going on and people are just so confused
why i'm hitting a [ __ ] blob for five
minutes
as you can see we do practically no
damage but our weapon luckily has bleed
on it so whenever that hits it does a
ton of damage so eventually it goes down
it just takes a while before he dies we
pop the golden foot that we got earlier
for that extra xp then we're off to the
round table hold for the first time the
reason we're here is to activate
bloodhound step which we got earlier we
then teleport back to the swamp area but
this time we're heading south instead
there's the starlight shard get the
rotten breast spell back to the third
church of america and now we're heading
south instead you can pick up these
crystal tears they're not really that
good but they're on the way
why not
same thing with this merchant he's on
the way he sells sleeper arrows we don't
necessarily need that many but he's
right there he's on the way it don't
matter we're heading to this castle
that's where we really want to go before
we enter we pick up this golden seed
so yeah this is the spot where you saw
me die earlier because there's a blood
night or something up here on the left
and since i died here before i'm always
super nervous running up seeing if he
follows me or not he is but he's way too
slow so we're totally fine up here we
find the first half of the medallion
which is necessary to progress in the
game and i decided to sacrifice my runes
to get out of there it's just not worth
it and we're back to finish up the last
two things that we need by this bonfire
first we're heading down if you remember
earlier when i was talking about
summerstone eight and nine this is where
you get them so this one drops number
eight the best way to deal with them is
just push them off the cliff
i love doing it
i don't have to do this parkour jump
it's very easy but it still makes me
nervous because if i mess up i
technically die and again it's not a
speed run but i don't know it'd be kind
of lame to just run around the whole god
damn thing down here is a rune arc which
we'll definitely need later but it's
also most importantly summerstone number
nine as you can see this summer stone is
not on the ellen ring wiki by the way so
there you go a secret for you and then
we teleport back to the same bonfire for
the last time this time though we're
heading into the castle behind us where
we find the other half of the medallion
from earlier
but wait we're not done here we're
actually heading deeper in
i've learned my lesson to use bloodhound
step here get writing on sword seal
which is a great talisman and then we're
off back to limb grab get the starlight
shard get the bone and be
we'll come back here later the next 30
minutes is pretty much just running
around and as boring as that is i've
always feel really good being here
because there's pretty much nothing that
can kill us for a very long time so i
get to breathe out a little bit here you
have to snap this wolf church of eric
get that tear we're picking up whatever
upgrades we can on the way you know
we're running the secret pass to skip
the first two bosses we'll come back
when we're a bit stronger grab the bond
we'll come back here through the portal
again i've died from this stupid jump so
it gives me anxiety every time pick up
some runes because we're pick up gang
like that we get the key and then we get
the [ __ ] out hey remember how i said
there's no more scary bits anymore well
i forgot to kill a boss so we had to go
back here just setting up and then we're
good to go i used to hate this boss
because he's easy to mess up and at this
point you spent 30 to 40 minutes that
you don't want to redo trust me his
attacks are super slow you can stagger
him with rock sling unless he pulls out
some surprises which he definitely can
he's not that bad
see he charged me there but i was lucky
with the stagger
and we got our moon well baby i felt so
confident here it felt really good now
we can continue the stuff that we need
to do by the lake first we had east and
we pick up a talisman
we'll get the talisman and then we head
back
now it's time to do the magma man
request
we just need to get a necklace back from
this lobster dude we just gotta pay him
a thousand runes and then we're done
with the quest and now we can progress
this is the area that we needed a key
for we'll come back here there's a
secret merchant down this way he sells
the same sleeper arrows that we got
earlier just way more of them now we
head through the other gate
another church another upgrade we need
to go to the giant structure on the
right but before we do that we can pick
up number three that's right pickup game
pick up the bonfire and then we head
through the elevator this is why we
grabbed the two medallion parts earlier
because otherwise you're not allowed to
pass
posture girl can now get us to magma
manor
get that bonfire join the mama family
secret door you probably know about it
sneak gang i love this area i think it's
the coolest looking in the game we have
some parkour to do here it's super easy
but i'm always so nervous because if i
mess it up i will die so
that bloodhound step is coming very
handy right now just surfing the a lot
of waves it's whatever no big deal
so yeah now we're finally what i was
talking about earlier you can get all
the stones very easily we're still way
too low level to be here so you got to
be a little bit careful
number five pick up gang all right guys
don't judge me okay
at this point i will have the best
weapon and i feel confident i can easily
kill this boss the thing is
i i don't have to i can just tease him
why not okay why not why risk it it's a
[ __ ] boss i don't care now think
about it i definitely have enough arrows
to just sleep him anyway so but anyway
if you do this ritual before you enter
you can glitch him out and just smack
his ass as much as he want he ain't
gonna do nothing
and i swear it's more fun doing this
than actually trying to the boss so
zero that yeah
i forgot we haven't picked up seven yet
just a little bit of parkour
got on the first try everything looking
good oh [ __ ]
okay don't judge me
listen this is not a rule break i can
quit out i try to not do it because it
basically makes enemies not aggro on you
people use it all the time in speed runs
and stuff like that it's a little lame
but [ __ ] i'm i'm not restarting an hour
just because he randomly grabs me okay
lame sure rule break no zero death yes
so we take the elevator from the boston
room again i love this area it looks so
good with the llama but i'm always
scared running it
i hate running past this iron maiden and
i get stuck
trying to not freak out but we made it
in fine it's all right a little bit more
running and we find the portal to
ryker's boston room we're not gonna
fight him right away in fact we're gonna
go back to the very start oh yeah we can
almost max out our weapon now which is
pretty damn sweet i love clicking these
sorry now we head back it's a little
annoying we have to deal with this
invasion event but we also get to try
out our new weapons so it's kind of fun
too
head into the cage nearby meet the best
character in the game and i kill him by
mistake
oops
luckily we can still buy his items over
here i'm so glad they have this feature
he sells three golden foot which is
amazing and margaret's shackle which is
great for the boss
now finally it's time to slap the first
boss's ass
seeing how much i struggled on this boss
the first time it feels so damn good
every single time to do this amount of
damage on him you did
and we get a talisman pouch so now we
can add our red gun seal finally you
take more damage if you wear it but you
also gain more health and you deal more
damage i feel like the cost is pretty
nice
oh god the cost is pretty good
i'll come back to that one it's time to
enter the castle and you get to go
either the secret route or the main gate
but the main gate is by far superior
i always wonder where people kill him
but apparently he steals your runes so
this part is super easy because we have
bloodhound step otherwise it's a pain in
the neck so it's around 12 o'clock for
me here so i decided to take a break i
don't know if that's cheating or not but
uh i was i'm tired
day two baby and if it's not obvious
that i took a break here
i forgot that i hadn't beaten the boss
yet so i'm running into this area that i
can't progress in yet so yeah after
running all the way here's when i
realized oh yeah
i haven't done the boss
oops so i had to go back all the way to
this boss just because the game didn't
save my bonfire for whatever reason all
right so we have to run deeper into the
castle and we have to run past all these
guards it's just quicker that way and
honestly i think it's less risk just
trying to run past them but to be honest
running this bit even with bloodhound
step is really scary because it's just
such a mess you have the crossbows and
everything just shooting at you
just keep running keep running keep
running there's the elevator here that
we need to grab a dog snook in and i
hate them but thankfully we have the
moon wheel so no problem up we go
next up is godric and i actually think
he's easier than the boss we just fought
just because he's a bit more scripted so
he does certain moves when he's healthy
at a certain point but honestly any boss
is easy when we have this weapon at this
point
[Music]
i
you know this guy talks a lot for being
dead now we have to do the run that i
did by mistake earlier it takes a while
but it's definitely worth it i can't
believe i played the entire game the
first time without even knowing about
this godric's great rune baby
to use that we have to activate a rune
arc that we collected earlier except i'm
a goddamn idiot i've done this mistake
so many times you have to equip the rune
first luckily we can just buy it off the
old ladies it's okay all right activate
the rune this time
it makes it so that all our stats are
increased by five which is insane the
cost is that if you die you lose this
ability but lucky for us
we got no intentions of doing that
coolest boss room and maybe even boss in
the entire game coming up we are way too
low level for this boss but you get this
weapon which basically makes him into
easy mode finally we use our starlight
shot
they give you mana over time it's so we
don't have to worry about drinking
during the fight because we're not gonna
have any time to do that except using
this attack
over
and over and over
it's very cheesy i think it's fine this
is a gimmick boss after all
the thing is i cannot make any mistakes
if i miss my timing with half a second
there's enough time for him to attack me
and instantly kill me but as long as i'm
spamming this attack over and over he
can't really do anything so this looks
super simple but it is a high risk
pulling this off with zero deaths at
least my starlight shard eventually runs
outside only time i have to drink is
right here when he gets staggered then i
can finish him off again
he's dead but not yet so i used my
second starlight shard before phase two
same thing except now i have to move
backwards a tiny bit between every
strike that i do i can't go too far
because then i'll miss and if i miss
i'll die but i can't go too close
because then the lava will hit me and if
i hit the lava i die so it's a bit of a
dance which keeps it interesting but it
is
it is what it is
and he's dead using the gold foot here
and we get ourselves a [ __ ] ton of ruins
almost 200k just from that god damn hey
remember this area
well now we can actually progress
through this area without talking to the
lady
mainly we're just gonna have to run
around here grab some random items where
we can find them there's a ton of
upgrades in this area
just got to watch out for these
trebuchet catapults they will instantly
kill you it's always scary running past
stuff like this even though the risk is
low
so we're not quite inside yet we just
need to enter one more level of walls
morgan returns here for the second time
i think it's a secret boss and it's
really not necessary to kill him
he's just in my path that i'm going
through anyway and he drops a decent
talisman so whatever i'll kill him
two golden seeds and then two more right
after we're now ready to enter the city
but first we're gonna kill this tree
sentinel boss that guards the gate
there's no way to enter without killing
him so we sneak up behind him
and i don't know if you guys remember
the talisman that we grabbed earlier it
basically just make it possible for us
to use the rotten breath it's super
overpowered this spell it does damage
over time and i think it takes half his
health if we just decide to run away
so you can just use the rotten breath
wait a couple minutes and then do the
same thing again but that's just kind of
lame i know how to kill this guy
like here for example i can just run
away and he will die eventually but i
decided to have some fun with it
he is really fun to play with this bus
he just dodged this one later than you
think and it's actually super easy to
dodge
i decided to finish him up here
and now we can proudly run into the city
making it somewhat towards the end game
we'll be coming back here later this
jump is easy but it makes me anxious
get naked here for the aesthetic no it's
just so i can jump these roofs easier it
definitely helps to be naked when you're
doing that
nailed it now we can just run past the
guards there shouldn't be any problem
it's kind of funny how much time i spend
in the city the first time and then you
just
blast through everything dude i love
this area running off the dragon's wing
is so cool this game is insane
there's just a [ __ ] turner running here
there's not much to say about it there's
not much to worry about either nothing
really pops out of nowhere to kill you
and i always forget this boss i don't
know why it's an identical boss to
godfrey except it's way easier
i think since it's easier it's actually
kind of harder in a weird way he's
slower so the tempo that i'm used to
practicing is way off
and if he hits me with a one two i'm
dead so i always try and be way more
careful than i need to be
and dead baby
another talisman pouch nice
now we can wear a gun again
i need my sets to be a certain level at
this point i can't do too much damage on
this boss because it breaks my entire
flow that i have set up for him you'll
see now anyway so we will enter and then
just leave right away we'll use marga's
shackle that we got from the bald guy
that i killed by accident and if you use
it outside the boss room uh you
basically uh
it's not a cheat it's just a little cool
magic trick yeah
so as long as i don't hit him directly
he will just keep staying there until
his health bar goes to around 50
and before we allow that to happen we'll
blow rotten breath right in his [ __ ]
face
this is the last boss that i will cheese
i promise i promise
don't judge me
i feel like i could kill him easily
anyway right
i have died on him before so i'm always
nervous
luckily i have enough mono to use my
bloodhound step i didn't use it there
for whatever reason
all i have to do now is stay alive and
don't get hit
[Music]
even though i cheesed it i'm still hyped
about it
[ __ ] got him give the tree a little
sniff
talk the queef lady unfortunately i
gotta do this jump again i hate doing it
but it's worth it and phew we're fine
and now we're heading this way instead
to the elevator that we just got access
to sneak gang
there's a virus talisman here for the
fire giant later which i wish i knew
about a long time ago
we're just gonna make it across this
bridge then we're off to the winter area
winter area the snow area but not
without humiliating this guard
i don't have to kill him it's just fun
okay
and down we go even the most baby level
of jumps makes me nervous at this point
after two hours of meticulously trying
to not die everything makes me anxious
man
going up the grinder elevator first time
i played through this game i got clear
blue skies and this area looked
incredible it's really cool to play this
game again and see how it changes just
based on the weather being different as
much as i hate bridges i gotta admit
this bridge looks goddamn good man i
don't know why this area feels so barren
there's just so much running through
they have to do i'm pretty sure i don't
need any more of those past the ice lake
ignore the dragon find the church
oh yeah this is the best marisa comes in
look how focused i am
she comes in and waves my in my face
making her kick me as a joke
anyway i just thought it was funny but
clearly not at the time jesus christ
look at my face i'm so focused this area
is so cool
rip bird
after about 15 minutes of running we
finally make it to the fire giant but
before we deal with him there's a really
important item that i want to grab not
that not that either i really don't like
this area so i can't just run through it
but it's way safer for me to just deal
with all of these
one by one
and here's the item that i want it's the
bubble tier it's for the last boss when
he uses the chasing stars it makes it so
that i get healed instead of taking
damage from them
complete game changer so as risky as it
is to try and grab it it's definitely
worth it
now i'm ready for my arch nemesis the
fire giant put on that fire resistance
and let's go
since i fail him so many times there's
nothing he can throw at me at this point
i know exactly how to deal with this
dude
get the stagger keep tickling his toes
just gotta watch out for his balls
this is very risky but i knew i could
trigger phase two quick
this is so satisfying i get to blow run
breath right in his [ __ ] face
eat [ __ ]
so my new strategy
is to use rock sling from earlier
until he staggers and i get it right
away i was like yeah
i got you now
slice his face open
all i have to do now is stay alive
there it is baby
zero dips and i use a golden foot one of
my last two
for that extra xp felt so goddamn good
we commit the cardinal sin of touching
an unwedded maiden and now we're in the
goddamn end game
so much work to not even get to the
hardest bosses yet
oh hey summerstone 9 i really need that
yeah thanks
now it's time for the godskin duo i used
to think they were the hardest boss in
the game but we have a trick for it but
first we got to go back to the very
first bonfire that we grabbed
told you we'd be back here in two hours
it really doesn't look like it but you
can jump down here totally fine without
dying and we find another golden foot
another secret hidden merchant just
taking this chance to sell off
everything i've collected so far very
minimalist playthrough i know most
importantly the bow that he sells is
what we need
it's on baby i love this fight
so try and get three arrows in right
away and i get the sleeping effect
get another arrow in right away on this
second guy
start slapping him and do as much damage
as possible before he wakes up
and i gotta put a lot of trust that this
stagger happens and it does
he's dead
now i gotta deal with his friend in the
exact same way as before
get the bleed back off
get the stagger
you're dead son
now it gets a little tricky because i
have to sleep that chubby guy really
fast
for some reason i think he has more
health the second time he spawns
i don't know what's up with it but it
means that i have to start attacking him
while the animation of him falling
asleep is still happening otherwise i
don't have enough time to kill him
everything's working out perfectly here
i knew i had this boss
now we just got to finish off the slim
guy
for some reason i took it very carefully
here and it meant i got hit twice
but
yeah it's fine he's dead it don't matter
going to struggle so much on a boss to
then just have complete control is so
satisfying i know some people think
using the sleeper arrows is a cheesy way
to beat them
it's a complete [ __ ] boss without it
i don't mind using them for even a
second moving on we have some of the
worst running that i have to do in the
game and it's always fun to do that at
the very end stage isn't it
it's this area with the birds it's just
awful if you played it you know exactly
what i'm talking about luckily
bloodhound step coming in with a clutch
for the last time i would not be able to
do this without it i would have to quit
out constantly otherwise i don't know
it's just so bad the dragon keeps
spamming there's lightning attacks and
you're just hoping something doesn't hit
you he blows his [ __ ] breath on me
too like great thanks a lot
eventually he just disappears though so
it's fine and i get to grab the last
summer stone in the game finally we get
to max out they really want you to die
here don't they
bloodhound step here as well
so good
and then we take the elevator up to what
i think is the hardest boss malakai
but first we got to max out our weapon
of course always feels good ignoring my
poker face my adrenaline is running high
here man this is the farthest i've
gotten ever with these play throughs
malikith is my barrier
it's this weird dance that i have to do
him because i want to make him staggered
on phase two i build it up slowly if i
keep attacking him in phase one but i
can't do too fast because then it
triggers too early and i can't do it too
slow because then i'm screwed
but everything is just going perfectly
here that was so [ __ ] clean
i decided to commit
this fucker's going down
he's about to do the double spinny
attack it's so fast and if anything hits
me i'm dead
use my absolute last resources and i get
another last stagger i'm so [ __ ]
hyped
first time in two hours i show any form
of emotion
this is the furthest i've ever gotten
and i really didn't have to do this but
i knew there was a health talisman down
here and i figured hey if i'm gonna do
this i might as well go all out but i'd
be lying if i said i wasn't [ __ ]
myself trying to make this jump
so unnecessary dude next up is gideon i
haven't really spoken about him because
he's supposed to be the easiest boss in
the game
it's easy but he needs to die fast and i
can't let him heal oh god damn it dying
from gideon would be the worst thing
possible at this point
hit that bleed on the last one he's done
now there's only three bosses left
i'm [ __ ] hyped
next up is godfrey
i quit at right away because the second
time you enter he starts a further away
this is a little nicer way to set it up
i just have to keep my head cool at this
point
when he puts the axe in the ground he
always moves towards you so you have to
dodge it
i got greedy there
i can only attack him when his swing
stacks three times and he kept [ __ ]
doing it twice so i do minimal damage on
him here
finally
now i just have to keep my distance
[Music]
this really sucks because i dodged it
too early
and he grabs me i decided to quit out i
know that's a little lame but he also
means i gotta restart everything
finally phase two
i cannot mess up like that again no way
eventually this [ __ ] went down
hell yeah
i love that quote
let's go
after two hours and 40 minutes it's time
for the last boss i have my starlight
shard ready for each of the faces so i
am ready as ever for this i can get one
shot at this no quit that's possible
so [ __ ] clean
get that last starlight shard in
it actually didn't activate in time and
i didn't even notice but somehow because
of it
i got confidence to attack him more than
ever and i managed to stagger him
never seen this before
activate that goddamn shard this time
please so now he goes up in the air and
i need to run towards 11 o'clock-ish it
will make sense in a second if i do it
right i can get a couple extra hits in
the problem is i've forgotten to attach
my uchigatana which has the bloodhound
step on it
so i had to do that instead so he
managed to escape without me attacking
him here
i hate this attack
i got greedy
he pulls out the chasing stars
luckily the bubble tear comes to the
rescue
so
i knew i wouldn't get him all the way
down
but i didn't think i'd be this [ __ ]
close
jesus christ
that means he gets to go up in the sky
again for the last time
let's go
zero
[Music]
there you go the deed is done zero death
i know this one wasn't perfect and i did
use some cheap strategies here and there
i know there will be some people that
will have problems but
technically this is my own challenge so
i get to make my own rules
at the end of the day i am [ __ ]
thrilled that i got this as much as i
wish it was live with you guys it was a
huge moment doing something that i
actually didn't know if i could do or
not thank you to martial for putting up
with me being a hermit for a week
and to some friends from mine for giving
me input here and there i also gotta
give shout out to these three channels
because i watched a lot of their live
streams and it helped a ton i know now
from doing this and you as well for
watching a ridiculous amount about a
video game
it has absolutely no practical value
whatsoever
i can't think of anything more
meaningless but i gotta say at that
moment when i hit that goal
it definitely meant something
this is the last video i'm making before
i move
actually in sweden we hold our thumbs
so this video felt like a season finale
if you will as always appreciate your
support it was really fun working on
this and editing it and doing the whole
thing
it felt very old school so
in that spirit
hit that
congratulations all nordvpn click
linkers in the description we already
know for six billion times what a vpn
does it hides it from people and
protecting you for people spying and
stealing your data now nerdvpn is now
more than vpn they introducing a new
really cool feature called threat
protection you can just turn it on you
don't need to be connected to a vpn to
actually use this feature it gives you
another level of protection included in
what's already a really great service so
basically if you ever go on a website
they have a bunch of ads not only are
they super annoying but they can also
sometimes be harmful so if you
accidentally click on one of them you
can mess up your computer so threat
protection blocks these ads so you don't
have to even look at it they also scan
every single download that you do to
make sure that it isn't malware so if
someone sends you a suspicious file
great protection will take care of it
also it protects you from websites
collecting data on you and building
profiles it's one of those things that
people tell you they're like you know
these websites collect data from you
right and i'm like yeah all right
whatever and then they go well actually
you know they make a ton of money after
you like no
i can't do that activate threat
protection i will not let this happen it
protects you from fishing attempts and
giving you a safer cleaner and more
private web experience if you use the
link in the description you get a huge
discount on a two-year plan plus one
month for free you're welcome and you
can try it out for 30 days with the
money back guarantee so if you didn't
like it
may try it out link in the description